son de la pluie mais
j'ai mené dimanche pour tuer le mouiller
les qu'il me veut
des regrets anciens j'aime quand la
pluie me dire barbeau
e
je me souviens du temps tu me mets bien
mais l'orage passé il ne reste rien que
des feux du mot jure
et puis et chagrin les chemises se
balance sur la corde
g et les souvenirs d'antan
comme des vieux sage ce que tu m'aimes
montant contre x même si tu es son
propre aveu
15 euros
e
qu'est-ce que l'on se fout des autres on
en verra bien d'autres en effet la poule
où j'aime me rends à des méfaits
fouilles
bon que samba
g au nord de lima
j'aime quand les nuages je vadrouille
e
avec les soucis qui se baladent en
centrale
cette ère du jour frills aidé par dessus
avant que l'on soit vieux
l'entrejeu plus la chanson de la plus
critique toi et moi
tout ce n'est pas fini
que tu reviendras réponse que tu m'aimes
autant qu autrefois même si tu es en
outre pas avec un autre
qu'est-ce que l'on se fout des autres on
en verra bien d'autres en effet l'art
pour l'eau qui
écoute sombre semble triste tricot d'eau
traversant de part et d'autre
cet amour qui est une autre et je ne
veux pas d'autre on est faits l'un pour
l'autre
en effet l'un pour l'autre jean claude
vannier